season 9 of apex legends is right around
the corner
so if you're a fan of titanfall then all
signs are pointing to this season
tying into response sci-fi universe more
than ever
it's important to know how apex and
titanfall are intertwined
to understand what is on the way so we
are going to run you through the
timeline from the 2100s
all the way to current day and apex
which is 2735.
if you want to stay up to date on the
latest and greatest in apex and
titanfall then subscribe to our channel
and drop a like on this video to let us
know
you want more and of course there is
going to be a ton of spoilers in this
video
so if you haven't had a chance to finish
titanfall 2 read pathfinder's quest
or watch the stories from the outlands i
would highly recommend that you do that
beforehand
[Music]
in the early 2100s an asteroid hits
earth and devastates the planet
a new element is discovered from the
asteroid's impact that heinrich henry
hammond of hammond engineering
uses to invent interstellar travel this
propels earth's scientific advancements
allowing humanity to better access its
surrounding star systems
which become known as the chorus systems
hammond robotics is still very active to
this day throughout apex legends
going as far as sponsoring upcoming
legend forge before he was murdered by
revenan
who was revealed to be the first
similacram ever who was also
created by hammond robotics decades
later there are even rumors that henry
himself could still be alive according
to rinson mandalay
a man in talos claiming to be him at 650
years old with current day being 2735 in
apex this would actually line up well
with the beginning of the titanfall
story
over the next few centuries we see the
rise of hammond engineering and hammond
robotics
which later becomes the infamous
interstellar manufacturing corporation
but better known as the imc throughout
titanfall
and apex legends the imc's power grows
rapidly with the advancement of
interstellar exploration
and robotic ai with inventions such as
titans
spectres and marvins pathfinder is also
a marvin but he wouldn't be made
until much after the imc's discovery of
the frontier
the frontier is a far-off zone in space
that's unusually dense with habitable
star systems and resources
the planets on the frontier's outermost
edges are known as the outlands which
we've been learning about more and more
thanks to the stories from the outlines
in apex legends
but that's not all the first known
successful scan of simulacrum revenant
was recorded in 24-20 hammond robotics
may have created him but the syndicate
eventually controlled him
due to the core system's own depleting
resources the imc was quick to further
explore the frontier and expand
colonization
however as time went on the imc's
resources were split between the core
systems
and the frontier which caused the imc to
struggle to maintain corporate power in
the course systems
and made them completely withdraw their
resources from the frontier
to reinforce their hold back home anyone
left on the frontier was completely
abandoned by the imc
the imc eventually regained control of
the core systems with the help of the
first titans created for battle
however that would leave the core
systems exhausted and desperate for
resources
so they decided to return to the
frontier despite being cut off from the
imc
those left in the frontier had been
thriving and advancing on their own
for generations the inc immediately
returned to reclaim the frontier
begin manufacturing and displace the
frontier's existing residents
sparking the beginnings of another war
in 2640 billionaire humanitarian
lillian peck built olympus a city in the
sky of samathi which is a high-class
planet in the outlands
lillian peck discovered an imminent
energy crisis that threatened all of the
outlands
that many people didn't believe despite
the science behind
it with the help of astrophysicist dr
mary summers aka horizon
and the funding from companies such as
the imc hammond and chevrex
inc branthium is discovered and is the
key to ending the energy crisis
side note chef x inc is owned by
lifeline's family
however when retrieving the brandium
horizon is betrayed by her assistant
dr ashley reed and launched into a black
hole and left her dead for more than 80
years
over 15 years after the betrayal the
energy crisis of 55
is averted thanks to a group of
scientists who consisted of
many relatives to our favorite legends
such as gibraltar's grandfather a lucky
watson's grandmother emilia and
horizon's own son
newton the backstabbing dr ashley reed
was also among this legendary group
as a part of their plan to fix the
approaching energy crisis
the scientists created a specialized
marvin our favorite robotic pal
pathfinder
to save the outlands however reed
betrayed her allies to claim the
branthium for a mysterious employer
leaving her fellow scientists to fight
for their lives in order to protect it
the scientists were able to get the
branthem to the people against
all odds but everyone is said to have
died from this event
leaving a permanent rift on olympus the
details were largely hidden from the
public which had some people believing
the event and the crisis
itself never really happened and to
present day brampton is still
only owned by the extremely wealthy the
titan wars began as the return of the
imc to the frontier
led to the uprising of the frontier
militia who fought against the imc with
stolen titans in gear
but they weren't strong enough to
complete their mission and had to
retreat for a chance to fight another
day
the imc was able to claim gridiron as
the official center of imc operations
and established the first ever hammond
robotics titan factory
gridiron's location made planet demeter
a crucial stop between the core systems
and the frontier
and would serve as the gateway of travel
for the imc gridiron would also become
the home of bangalore as she
is a former imc soldier from a lineage
of imc soldiers
bangalore only has one brother who
didn't become a soldier
he instead became an imc scientist
stationed on typhon
typhon is also the home of renee hope
lazy who
we know better as wraith although
eventually she does end up on solace
the 2700s is where apex legends and
titanfall 2
start to collide more than ever the
militia managed to win the crucial
battle of demeter that left the imc
without their resources and gateway to
the chorus systems
over the next five years and cut off
from their reinforcements
the aries division within the imc led by
general martyr
discovered the fold weapon on typhon and
planned to use it to wipe out the
militia
during this time wraith would actually
become a scientist within the aries
division but ended up being the subject
of experiments
that wiped her memory although the
effect and cause level of titanfall 2
gives us a glimpse behind some of
wraith's abilities and strengthens the
connection between both games
as the fold weapon is nearing completion
general martyr is contracted to an elite
group of mercenary pilots
known as the apex predators who were led
by cumin blisk
to help secure and deliver the ark power
source to the weapon
this is the same cuban bliss that is the
current commissioner of the apex games
once the militia catches wind of this
plan they send out their forces to
typhon to stop them
among the first wave is rifleman jack
cooper who witnesses the brutal death of
captain lastomosa at the hands of bliss
being the only one to do so cooper
inherits lastomosa's mission to stop the
imc
and also his titan bt7274
throughout the mission cooper and bt
fight and defeat
all of the apex predators except for
bliss
among those apex predators that are
notable to our timeline today
are going to be ash and viper somehow dr
ashley reed was saved from the event
back on olympus
kind of now going by the name ash this
deadly predator was no longer human but
a simulacrum-like revenant and is
defeated
yet again after pitting cooper up
against a deadly simulation of her
own but if we learned anything from
revenant simulacrums tend to pop up
sooner or later she was eventually
remade by vincent dynamics and at some
point
blisk dismantles her and throws her
parts through a portal
to another dimension which the legends
ultimately find
in season five's quest the broken ghost
in the following season
ash was found by pathfinder with her
memory wiped
it's later revealed she's still working
with bliss and an old friend
presumably horizon is back and ash
leaves pathfinder behind
horizon returns the following season
having finally escaped the black hole
that reed trapped her in years prior
and as season 9 closes in ash has once
again popped her head
back into the fray by giving us a
special invitation to an upcoming arena
viper on the other hand was definitely
human but put up a tough fight to stop
the militia from getting closer to the
fold weapon
his north star titans missiles and
superior flying ability looked to be
too powerful but jack cooper is able to
stop him with the help of the 6-4
who are somewhat the counterparts of the
apex predators
among the group of pilots in the 6-4 is
drows
mirage's uncle viper was eventually
taken down by cooper and bt
and although he was a deadly threat he
also had a family
in the newest story from the outlands a
viper's daughter kyrie is revealed and
is the legacy season's debut legend who
goes by the calling card of valkyrie
out of vengeance for her father and
after attempting to kill blisk valkyrie
ends up getting a bliss card to the apex
games
and rampart's assistance to build a
specialized veto
jet pack from her father's north star
titan it should be pretty interesting to
see how viper and mirage are going to
interact with each other in the future
with a viper out of the way cooper and
bt eventually take down blisk's last
remaining predator and make it to the
fold weapon
by now blisk's contract was completed
and the power source was delivered
so he didn't feel the need to end
cooper's life despite general martyr's
pleas
to do so instead bliss tossed him a card
to join the apex predators and
bounced when the frontier's gladiator
thunderdome matches stopped
bliss would later revitalize them as a
fully fledged battle royale called the
apex games
the only way into the games if you
didn't get this special bliss card is to
pass the qualifiers like bangalore or
gibraltar
or be sponsored like forge or fuse
unless you're crypto of course
this obviously raises the question of if
and when
we're gonna see cooper in the apex games
thanks to bt's noble sacrifice the
weapon was stopped at the cost of typhon
including bangalore scientist's brother
who was stationed on the planet at the
time
eventually militia forces stormed
gridiron where bangalore and her
brother's battalion made a last-ditch
effort to run away
by stealing an archard from their imc
labs on gridiron
although bangalore wanted to use it to
blast the militia away
the battalion successfully escaped and
ended up catapulting themselves to the
outlands
a trip that would normally take 20 years
only took them one
shortly after this chaotic event a
massive communications blackout would
disconnect
the outlands from the frontier and
bangalore would lose another brother to
a freak accident over solas where he was
ejected from the ship
after it was hit by a mysterious
explosion civil war among the outlands
broke out and so the syndicate treaty
was signed in 27-23
salvo is the most recent planet to join
the synagogue space after originally
denying it in the past
but the desire to compete in the apex
games made fuse push salvo to join the
treaty
the apex games were a spiritual
successor to the popular thunderdome
bloodsport held by the now defunct imc
and officially opened around 2728
blisk's role in both titanfall 2
and apex legends is one of the biggest
connections between the two titles
as he is the source of many things even
outside of the apex games
blisk also has deep ties to the
syndicate who's been looming in the
shadows for
centuries and you can't forget that he's
an extremely deadly apex predator
from what we've seen so far a lot of
loosens from blisk's paths are looping
back around with each passing season
which is bringing us even closer to
titanfall lore
season 9 is reaching right into the
titanfall 2 bucket by reintroducing
viper through valkyrie's backstory
along with even more antics from ash who
we just can't seem to get rid of
after seeing the two timelines and how
they work together it's clear
more than ever that this universe is
about to expand
i know many are patiently waiting on
titanfall 3 but
in my opinion the more the universe
grows through apex legends
the more impact another titanfall will
have so what do you guys think of how
apex legends is tying into the titanfall
universe
is there anything you want to see come
to apex from titanfall 2. go ahead and
let me know down below and of course
stay tuned to the channel because we are
going to have so much apex goodness as
season 9 approaches
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you